you do s'excuse aujourd'hui on se
retrouve une nouvelle fois pour discuter
avec lui qui est cet homme jackson salut
je suis le nouveau mec bois bottes
bonjour bois bottes mais que fais tu là
je ne m'appelle pas france oui bah tu es
moi je m'appelle françoise tanghe lui
pourquoi mais je te baise mais je te
prends un verre sur la gare you bon gars
tué l'amant secret des vies a souri
il sort il a pourtant ils sont d'abord
les nuits passées avec et vit en france
en grèce y compris salade 100 à 120 par
an ces sangliers mais je vais bientôt
mourir autant mourir de quoi je veux y
mourir
d'accord mourir de quoi tu t'appelles
comment as tu en survêt quand tu me dis
que tu vas mourir et des arts tu me
demande comment je m'appelle s'il ya un
problème et hussein illuminati un
illuminati qu'est ce donc un triangle
avec un oeil beaucoup et moi [ __ ] mais
attends mais là je n'irai pas dans les
discussions normales ont froid du début
bonjour bonjour mon amour ah ouais il
est comme ça il est comme ça moi bottes
tu veux me pécho oui au nickel il va
cacher
désolé je cherche pas l'amour tu ne me
plaît pas c'est vrai par contre je
cherche à faire l'amour
[Musique]
je dis moi la vérité sur mes abonnés
elle a du mal à la trouver le pot est là
en plein boys - année oui ni non
j'ai des couguars machine c'est vrai moi
je fais dprk en ciel tu me réponds plus
correctement mille questions mais ces
méta même pas posé une question [ __ ]
il est arrogant redescend mais j'allais
là plutôt badoit ou san pellegrino
comment tu t'appelles je te baise je
suis robin non tués principalement bleus
je suis aquaman moi je suis brun aux
yeux bleus c'est intéressant
oui mais pas tout le pan aimes-tu le
body de beyoncé oui mais je ne peux pas
en manger à lui il est vraiment cache
quoi je te mange les oreilles aux
planches un peu plus de me prendre des
stocks par des ordinateurs dix mois mon
futur
ces discussions ne mène à rien mais
c'était hyper violent j'en ai marre je
veux savoir mon futur tu veux savoir
quoi alors décision mon futur un mec
comme ça il ya un gros problème dans
l'histoire ce que je vais devenir bien
coupé règle le sort des dix mois où nous
mènera cette chaîne youtube avec une
complainte amoureuse je vais te mettre
une corde autour de ton cou boiboite
j'appelle la police
je m'appelle julie a dû changer de
discours dacquois fils de chien
oui je fais apparaître des manivelles et
je fais des blagues pas drôles aux ok
bon je dois te laisser bisouter pas
intéressés par ma manivelle je suis
chargé du poids il a osé connais tu as
une peu plus connus non je veux te pécho
a alors une petite analyse par animal
préféré alors tu penses tu de la
virilité en 2015 ça c'est une question
très importante pour nous je pense que
le nom mais je fais chanter pour moi je
pense que j'en ai besoin
ils vont arriver chez moi ni quantifiés
eu marre et plus à part rapporte tout à
l'heure ce que tu as dit à 86 coop à
deux normales battu un psychopathe
assume et toi tu m'as donné son tu vois
tu penses à parce que je suis pas viril
ses prix mais j'assume
bah voila voila je te pète je suis ton
ex petit ami alors qu'est mon petit ami
actuel but je ne sais pas mais mieux si
c'est elle je peux t'assurer que c'est
fou je peux t'assurer qu'il ne disait
pas ça y est alors
c'est le plus gros peyrelade internet le
bon dieu merci c'est très gentil mais
que l'un bourses ont eu lieu au merci
c'est tout chaud
derrien bébé dedans mais leïla en mode
attaque quoi tu veux me pécho moi où je
suis je suis un recours allez moi aussi
je suis bender de futurama là je vois
qu'on s'est pris la phrase d'un canadien
d'un québécois rrq et sur le site que
compensent ce que je peux plus alors
cette faute laval a réglé une fois pour
toute et maintenant l'orthographe avec
squeeze ce avec un v6 généralement
précédés de il l exemple ils se lavent
ce avec un c désigne quelque chose par
exemple ce que tu me dis voilà aucune
base pour les tu veux faire une coupe de
cheveux style est dans le doute on c'est
lui là des petites pêches un petit peu
de bg là je vais te briser le cou bah
voila voila dans le doute on n'aurait
pas dû tu aimes mes tétons je ne le fais
pas tu le tiens je te les montres gelé
ce qui est trop longue à cap après les
avoir violées à rennes mais c'est la
psychopathe sans les connaître
qui est le meilleur youtuber francophone
mais dites vous à cacher des choses trop
franc qui est le meilleur
myners francophones en cause d'une eau
qui est l'homme le plus drôle de france
le point bas sera couplé bord tu devrais
avoir une chaîne youtube
pourquoi parce que tu prendre l argent
aux abonnés à cette expression me fera
toujours rire bordel voivod tout seul
c'est pas mal ça comme nom de chêne
voivod fait le con ça te plaît bon ok ok
ok arrête arrête c'est presque un
bastion ça suffit boiboite que penses tu
de ma chaîne youtube par feu mais
parfois lourde à basse vitesse ça fait
mal en plein coeur tu mets un j'aime pas
toutes mes vidéos parce que je fais je
me manon mme espécier un pouce bleus à
côté et ben alors pourquoi tu cliques
pas dessus que ce rêve dans le futur tu
sur une barre dans le futur il est trop
mystique a bien conclu jours
[Musique]
t
voilà les gens sont déjà fin de cette
vidéo avec bois bottes ont préféré et
vie oui il est très décevant bon
effectif dtsp que d'insultés de nous
recaler et n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
ça vous a plu au sens très bien ça dans
une prochaine
donc moi je finis en position foetale
jusque bois bottes m'a vraiment
rabaisser plus bas que terre
on s'entend très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo cas où tout le monde puisse
[Musique]